pilot to Bombardier [ __ ] pilot to
Bombardier we're going deep on the
Lord's Day [ __ ]
you
reporting from the garden the good and
evil pops up his uncle Joey Diaz it's
cloudy it's rainy but it's still a
beautiful [ __ ] day to be alive
you know why but you got the Holy Smoke
baby that's why I don't got much today I
got [ __ ] in the podcast at 6:00 a
little light workout today gonna meet a
friend for [ __ ] coffee gonna eat
lunch at the family and that's it that's
it but you know what I'm relaxing I'm
getting ready for a big week we got
Portland [ __ ] Thursday Friday
Saturday so I gotta get ready for that I
gotta get ready for two big podcasts I
just gotta get ready you got always be
[ __ ] ready understand me at Sunday
today's the day you regroup you eat your
vitamin C you [ __ ] make your notes
for the week you ran out your
[ __ ] goals and the rest falls
into place you understand me
oh [ __ ]
little football never kill nobody either
we got the tail into the hardcore we got
the tail under the Skywalk when I got
off the hook with you [ __ ] I'm
going right for the week still oh we saw
opens at 10:00 I'm there at 1001 you
don't understand me you know why cuz I'm
always at [ __ ] attention gotta be an
attention you understand you can set
your [ __ ] watch to uncle Joey that's
how [ __ ] smooth I am besides that is
the same [ __ ] people trying to put the
pieces together the special comes out on
seeso TV December 8th you're gonna get
it for free your code
Joey bad and you got the special right
there
I love this getting together with you
[ __ ] just for a quick puff
before the day begins and we get [ __ ]
bombarded with [ __ ] jerk-offs people
with stupid [ __ ] opinions you know
there's always something [ __ ]
coming out of the woodwork you know I'd
do something different because I'm this
[ __ ] really suck my dick and
call me shorty [ __ ] we work at 7:24
here and always accompanied by the Holy
Smoke you understand me
what's it I'm not gonna show him you
think I'm gonna show up with a guy's
here look who I'm so cool look whom I
have as a friend I don't listen this is
my [ __ ] friend those cats my wife the
baby well at the end of the day
[ __ ] I'm a one-man parade [ __ ]
I'm Mike De Niro and Goodfellas you
understand me Jimmy was a one-man
[ __ ] parade and that's me
[ __ ] and you know it you know
it I can put up I could be put on a
[ __ ] Island as long as they got
reforge it cutlets and cranberry juice
I'm brand-new throw a [ __ ] kettlebell
in there come on now
I can swim do kettlebells I gotta talk
to you and get out the [ __ ] face
bookie suck my dick
look at that that's what it's all about
okay rob him with the big boys here on
the [ __ ] Lord's Day I went to church
this morning 7:30 mess went in there got
a cookie put a ten in the basket and got
the [ __ ] out of there now I'm need to be
lingering with those people next thing
you know I'm in the backroom there
blowing pedophile smoke in my face bet
if I smoke boat number three [ __ ] and
this [ __ ] debt do you understand me hey
I'm with you you're with me and they
want to be with us cuz they ain't got
dick but they can't just jump over
because they gotta get rid of the hat
and the glasses and their fake [ __ ]
phony friends you know they got this I
would do anything for Chad get the [ __ ]
out of my face first time you get
collect ball from county jail at 3 in
the morning you'll take me off your
[ __ ] Facebook friends list you
understand me and that's the
[ __ ] I want to answer in the
phone I got to go to church this morning
out of Pearlie and I called too flat to
read people and one of my buddies picked
up the phone it was like seven in the
[ __ ] morning over New Jersey picked
up the [ __ ] phone just to make sure
there was nothing going on and I got off
the phone I said how lucky am I to have
that [ __ ] Savage the rest of
these people nobody answers the phone la
I called my buddy a fourth day in the
[ __ ] morning he answers the phone of
the attention just to make sure I didn't
need something that's the type of friend
you want to have the understand the rest
of these jerk-offs the [ __ ] out of my
face
that's a cloud if I have the [ __ ] you
saw what understanding
I got no football fix that I'm no the
folks playing and I don't give a [ __ ] do
I give a [ __ ] that's how we're gonna
make it happen this week you understand
me
shout out to Porto Rican Nelson that's
my dog
somewhere walking around with a [ __ ]
towel right now I love you [ __ ]
with all my heart tonight 6 o'clock
Podcast Tuesday 8 o'clock Greg Proops
we're gonna be rocking wrong this
[ __ ] week all right I love you guys
see you tonight at 6:00 if not I'll see
you Thursday at the [ __ ] now
Portland helium ready to rock after that
I'm gonna go to the food truck and get a
[ __ ] gyro and smoke dope I love Paula
Nora can you understand me but I love
you [ __ ] more than when I told
you it's your lucky week [ __ ] there's a
[ __ ] what happened last week or the week
before I know it's a hard time of the
year for some people but they grab your
balls scratch the size of your little
dick sniff your fingers and go you know
what this year I'm not getting depressed
I got uncle Joey and I'm going for it
[ __ ]
one thing about Castro he's a thousand
things but if it wasn't for him I
wouldn't be here with you [ __ ]
making it happen he understand me
think about Castro is he put my family
how to get out of a hole so the [ __ ]
jeans they taught me how to get out of a
[ __ ] home and Here I am with you
[ __ ] but talk is cheap [ __ ] talk is
cheap the proof is in the [ __ ]
pudding
and I'm still here with you
[ __ ] every day I'm not perfect
I'm a [ __ ] loser but you know what I
don't give a [ __ ] you got to shoot me in
the heart with a [ __ ] bottle lying
and stab me cuz that's how we do it
you're losing before you even leave the
house [ __ ] soon as your [ __ ] floor
feet touch that floor you gotta thank
God to give you another day to stab a
[ __ ] my neck and make it happen
in your life you understand me and
beside that that's it and that's that
I'm gonna go smoke Marius I'm gonna go
buy more reason and I'll see you
[ __ ] tonight at 6 o'clock
be there I'll be sweat you know I love
your mother [ __ ] wrong by law yet
they didn't get my matter now ping diary
you know why cuz you're bad [ __ ]
oh yeah all these they get it with my
lawyer see that my connect I'm I'm a
dead man I get my mother wrote the gulo
I don't feel so I see I said it and so
will you I'll catch you [ __ ] on
the flip side